hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we are back with a
special hunter hunter video packed thing
with all sorts of dark continenty
goodness because we are here to explore
the bizarrely credible theory that
krapika's peeps also known as the kurt
clan
may have originated from the dark
continent and as with all theories i
want to recognize that yes that does
sound a little bit ridiculous at first
but stick with me here because there is
a fair bit of substance this one and it
also aims to solve some of the lingering
mysteries of the kurt clan itself a
shockingly underdeveloped aspect of
hunter hunter
and it's all going to begin with a quick
round of scarlet eyes or delicious fries
a very simple mini-game the rules of
which are as follows karapika is on a
quest to find the eyes of his clan
members and he has tracked down this
mystery box
it is now going to be your job to guess
what crappiker finds inside will it be
scarlet eyes or will it be a box of
delicious fries
should you guess incorrectly then your
punishment will be to subscribe to the
new world review thus resulting in
consistent injections of hunter-related
culture administered directly into your
youtube feed and if you are correct then
you will get to eat whatever was in the
box
om nom nom so what will it be scarlet
eyes or delicious fries make your choice
now and we shall reveal the answer in
three two one and bam it was scarlet
eyes because karapika has no time for
fries but if you guessed incorrectly
then you know thing to do and please do
say hi in the comments below if you are
a new member of the new world
association welcome now the scarlet eyes
are important because they form the crux
of the curta dark constant theory
primarily because their power cannot
actually be explained by any established
system of hunter hunter by which
i guess i mean nen everything is none
however the kurta eyes are an aberration
even in a series full of unique powers
and whenever a power lands outside of
nen explanation in the series the answer
to that problem is almost certainly the
dark continent
now as a quick recap the kurt clan as we
know them hailed from the luxo province
and
well we don't actually know because it
was never revealed exactly where it is
on the world map or even vaguely where
it is but it is somewhere
assumedly what we do know is that this
was a natural secluded and isolated area
of the world the kurt's clan are the
only known inhabitants of this area and
their tribe once consisted of 128
members including karapika and it now
consists of exactly one member
including karapika and what's important
to note right here is that not every
clan member possessed the signature code
to scarlet eyes in fact only 37 of the
128 members were said to have the eyes
so that immediately points to a natural
biological phenomena as opposed to any
kind of latent none-based power
it doesn't rule men out entirely which
we will get to but it does make it far
less likely one of the most curious
things about the scarlet eyes though is
that we have no real idea
what if anything they do those in the
kodak clan who were able to access them
had the ability to turn them on and off
and uh that's kind of it sort of like a
glorified light switch no greater
expansion was ever given and we only
have the case of kerapaka to examine
in his instance donning the scarlet eyes
changes his net affinity from conjurer
to specialist which is an ability that
no other character in the series has
ever possessed some
individuals do evolve naturally into
specialists over time but they can't cut
back and forth like rapica but the
problem is with only one case available
it is impossible to say for certain that
this would have been the same effect for
the entire clan
if anything it's entirely possible that
krapika could have subconsciously
created this affinity shift as an
ability itself by linking it to the
condition of the scarlet eyes sort of
like how bisky subconsciously created
her body transformation it was just bred
out of a deeply rooted desire
an effective response to a critical need
which also very much describes garappaka
because you can do
almost literally anything with nen which
is why the idea that karapika is an aura
user has very much actually poisoned any
hope we have
of ever understanding the kurt clan in
their natural form whatever the case
kraka's accomplishments with the eyes
actively break
the established rules of power in hunter
hunter and there is definitely precedent
for that but
most of those instances can be traced
back directly to the dark continent for
example the biological phenomena of the
five threats each one of which would be
capable of wiping out humanity if left
unchecked
these beings all possess seemingly
naturally developed characteristics
unlinked to nenus although the only
argument i could make for one that does
use nen might be i better known as
nanika
and better known than that as alaka and
that's mostly because i have a lot of
trouble believing that the god like wish
granting can exist without
some kind of aura manipulation i mean if
that is the case then
well hunter hunter is certainly broken
but the scarlet eyes are much more akin
to the other dark continent life forms
it seems extremely likely that some sort
of ancient group of what would become
the kurta clan
developed the scala dies as a survival
mechanism to live on the dark continent
and the reason why i pretty immediately
jumped to that conclusion all has to do
with a man by the name of beyond netero
this certified sneaky man said something
quite fascinating in his first
appearance in the series during chapter
340 in a live broadcast announcing not
only the existence of the dark continent
to the world which firstly
wow that was meant to be a bit of a
secret but he also went on to claim that
the ancient ancestors of humans
originated from the dark continent and
there's only so much stock you can put
into this because
it's beyond and he's far from a reliable
source of information at this point
but with that said our evidence would
seem to support his claim and it's not
just the kurdiclan either there are all
sorts of small strange teas in hunter
hunter another example of which is that
killer can morph his hands into these
beastial claws and he was able to do
this prior to becoming an end user
indicating a more biologically based
ability and even if we do ignore beyond
we do have at least one solid precedent
for humans living on the dark continent
in the form of dawn freaks so it's
definitely possible for humanity to
coexist with the other extraordinarily
deadly organisms just under the right
circumstances and if we were to take
beyond's hypothesis to a natural
conclusion then these various human
tribes and organizations living on the
continent could have migrated to the
center of lake mobius and settled there
in its various locations thus founding
the human realm although there is a bit
of a question as to
how because modern human society is
barely capable of traveling through such
deep and dangerous ocean so it's hard to
imagine a more ancient society having
the means of doing so however to be fair
even modern day humanity needs the help
of the gatekeeper and the guide to
successfully land on the dark continent
so perhaps ancient humans had some
assistance in that regard although the
other option is that the kurt clan
arrived in the human realm in the same
way that most dark continent creatures
do which is a curse that humans have
been forced to bring back with them
after an unsuccessful voyage
in that way i could see a situation
where the progenitor of the kurta clan
traveled to the dark continent and was
afflicted with the scarlet eyes as
punishment then this person returns
starts family and passes on this
biological characteristic and then
eventually we have this whole like mini
clan of just
red-eyed little people a whole clan who
are forced to live in isolation because
greater human society
will not accept them and just as a side
tangent that's something i've always
found a bit odd about hunt hunter the
kurdish clan were actively persecuted
and feared for the crime of having red
eyes but at the same time the world is
perfectly fine living side by side with
all of the weird and wacky magical
beasts in hunt hunter and i mean the
secretary of the hunter association is
literally like an anthropomorphic
bean plant so are you really telling me
that some lovely red eyes concern you
but a living vegetable does not
yeah you think about that unless of
course those who persecuted the
kurdiclan knew something that we do not
maybe it's not an entirely baseless fear
because if they are in fact a race from
the dark continent or afflicted by a
dark continent curse then the history of
hunt hunter tells us that this is
something to be
very very wary of the chimera ants for
example came close to completely
conquering humanity within a mere couple
of months of just
existing so there could very much be a
known history on whatever continent the
luxor province has housed where a kurt
clan member being accidentally or
intentionally caused some kind of
horrific incident
stories were passed down and thus people
at large are still afraid of the scarlet
eyes to this very day
and in an interesting left turn that
takes us to the phantom troop a complex
group of characters who are
simultaneously selfish and somehow
charitable twisted as it may be they do
have their own moral compass one which
abhors one type of genocide and one
which
actively accepts another type of
genocide like i said they're complex but
on the good end of that spectrum this
group is very loyal to one another as
well as their home of meteor city so if
there was a widespread fear of the kurt
clan who have been literally referred to
as devils then the phantom troop may
have seen them as a fair target one that
would not only make them a lot of money
but also solve a problem of the world or
even better than that
seeing the clan as an opportunity to
enact simple vengeance
because another thing i've always found
odd about hunter hunter is the note left
behind by the phantom troop after the
kurta massacre because
just why i mean firstly it makes very
little sense because if you think you've
killed the entire clan who's going to
read the message anyway and if someone
from the outside does stumble upon it
what exactly are they supposed to gauge
from that message
because it almost very patriotically
states the motto of meteor city being
we'll accept anything you leave here
but don't ever take anything away from
us and it just doesn't quite fit because
why is that message relevant
in the case of the kurt clan and with
that message in mind it almost seems
like a sort of retaliatory attack on the
clan
as if at some stage in the past a kurta
clan member did take something or
someone from meteor city and this brutal
massacre was a form of vengeance being
carried out in addition to an economic
opportunity of course
mancholo does need his fancy expensive
clothes after all but now we should also
go through a non-dark consonant
possibility because there is a chance
that the eyes are indeed men based i
mean the modern kurt clan members
themselves have no concept of it but
inherited nen is not foreign to hunt
hunter and the kakian empire pretty
blatantly display that the aura of the
first king of the kakin empire does
still exist and it interacts with his
descendants through the succession wars
so it is theoretically possible to think
that an ancient member of the kurta clan
could have developed the scarlet eyes as
a unique non-ability and then passed
them on through a post-mortem then
legacy and look we also do need to
examine the biggest sort of gaping floor
with the hulker to clean dark consonant
theory which
is yoshihiro togashi himself in fact the
main problem with hunt hunter theories
in general is that we always need to
apply this
logical declension via study of the meta
aspects of the series because with all
of that in mind the truth is likely that
togashi created the story of the kurta
clan long before he actually develops
the concept of nen tagashi is well known
as an improvised author and in my
opinion nen was not a planned power
system at the beginning of hunter hunter
which is why we now have inconsistencies
like the scarlet
eyes and killer's claws that just don't
fit nicely into the nen system along
with the existences like the early
magical beasts it's pretty clear that
togashi intended hunter to be more of a
fantasy style world before making the
abrupt switch to a more realist one so
there is absolutely no hope of the
thought that oh togashi intended the
kurt clan to be from the dark consonant
all along
because i guarantee that togashi had no
thoughts of the dark consonant at the
time either however it does work
as a good retroactive explanation like
how the dark continent was retroactively
used to explain the existence of the
chimera ants because considering that
the chimera antarct took togashi seven
years to draw i'm gonna go out on a
pretty safe limb here and say that he
had no plans for the dark consonant when
he first created the ants either it's
just not a very tagashi-like thing to do
to plan that far in advance but with
that said the dark continent is a stroke
of narrative brilliance in my opinion
the idea that this place exists
solves almost every weird world-building
inconsistency that togashi accidentally
crafted so no matter what explanation
occurs i think it's a safe bet to
attribute the scarlet eyes to the dark
continent whether they're a curse or a
kurta clan member descended from an
ancient race of humans who migrated it
just makes sense
and in a way it also ties into very
nicely with what's happening in current
events with karapika on his way to the
dark continent with the mission of
claiming the last of the scarlet eyes
during the journey this is almost
becoming an unintentional pilgrimage
garappica is setting sail to the direct
source of his life's journey the source
of his clan's historical persecution and
if we ever did
you know actually and get to the dark
continent then i would very much look
forward to seeing what karapika
discovers that
in the meantime how about you discover
video this one for example there's
always more to learn explore and enjoy
about hunter hunter so i look forward to
seeing you there